this ideology is already in government
like I remember I was at I got a Wendy's
in Pennsylvania or something okay and on
the wall like when you walk in the left
was like their statement of like equal
rights and all that and it included all
of this gender ideology and other stuff
and I'm like mm-hmm that's just weird
yeah it's like I I get it that we don't
really have to worry about it like it's
a fair point to say there's there's
rarely if ever a dude walking in the
ones bathroom guess the woman trying to
you know pretending to be trans or
something if a dude really wanted to go
in they just do it you know there's
other ways that guys good point so I
write I think it's a silly argument when
they're like oh no what if men do these
things what do they do now I mean
whatever but the issue isn't probably do
do them they do and they probably always
done it exactly the issue is legal
protections like school programs for
women mm-hm and sports programs for I
should say females for biological
females right so this is where the civil
rights are being destroyed by this
ideology so I'll tell you straight on
and women's rights also yeah seriously
what I mean like but it's civil rights
as a whole you're right yeah if you
could identify as anything you want then
you can be trans racial yeah and there
are people who art are actively doing
this yeah and there was was at Brown
University allows you to identify as POC
if you'd like I think so yeah yeah it
was brown absolutely nuts it's like he
just found a form like I am the POC
there you go
and then you can ask for the benefits
that come along with it and I'm like
well then why it's just it's a it's
ridiculous what did people fight for
seriously I guess the issue is because
now you're basically taking away the
protections by opening up to everybody
right yeah so I don't know you solve for
that I guess you got to create a special
special programs for certain individuals
or or it can't be done there's no
there's no point which you can rest and
say we've accomplished civil rights
because it's always changing yeah so we
heard about the civil that the slippery
slope argument from conservatives 20
years ago
like if oh if we enact gay marriage this
is what comes next
some of these things have come next yeah
I mostly don't care about a lot of these
things like if somebody wants use the
bathroom there's like your if they want
to identify as a dear like okay yeah I
don't care right don't power trip
but there there there there is a fair
point about the slippery slope that's
come you know 20 years ago and it's
tilts here today yeah is about like well
we have to create a new sporting
division for deer probably if they want
to identify as a deer and gotten Pete in
depth boards then yeah I don't think
they take like you know deer hormone
your jump really well so what about the
tiger person or the tiger person mm-hmm
that got surgically altered to look like
a tiger no I must have missed on that so
yeah yeah that was back when I had my
blinders on now this is a famous TV show
personality in like oh I well-known
figure I don't know alakazam is mouth
split got face tattoos of tiger and got
fake whiskers put in and I believe was
it was it was a transgender transpose XI
tiger not exaggerating at all okay so so
do we do we recognize object I have to
see this yeah I mean I mean this with
the utmost respect no disrespect is are
legitimate questions I'm trying to ask
I'm not trying to be mean anybody I
legitimately I'm curious if other kin
will become protected under the law
because if the law in New York says self
expression is part of the definition of
gender identity then if your self
expression is that you are a you know
Dragon Lord named as an Theon that's
pretty cool actually sounds good yeah
man I mean you know you want to be
Dragon Lord and you you get like you
know you wear a wingsuit and you have a
scepter and a helmet and you walk around
saying you are a Xanthian the human form
of the Dragonborn and you and and that's
your name to what extent do I have to
partake what you I think it's I have I
half-expected a skyrim shout yeah you
walk in the Starbucks
what can I get you what can I get you
sir boost wrong and the guys like the
cup just goes flying up ya know you're
applying the other kid actually has a
shot powers no no but dragon can yes
maybe
Dragonborn Dragonborn has some approving
yet so so I think it was Jordan Peterson
who said to what extent do I have to
entertain yeah what did he call it where
do you draw the line he didn't call it a
fantasy he was very common dating but
he's like where does my
right to call call it like I see it and
yeah so if we say again yeah yeah
basically bordering on freedom of speech
where does that end well that was a
point what it is yeah okay legitimate
question because uh the argument and
I've heard the answers are not given to
you the first question is if you want to
identify as the as something else and
right now you know transgender is the
thing they say well that literally
exists within you the DNA for this the
you know it's part of being human right
but we're also we're related to every
animal if you trace it back far enough
that's so so all related to a banana
whatever same money you bring I identify
as a banana well so this is the other
argument right so the argument the
responses you know when you say why
would I have to entertain your you know
identity you know why can't I call you
what I want they say it's respectful and
then they argue then the next argument
was trans racialism well the people who
are trans racial are asking for the
exact same thing they say oh well but
they're not really that race wait so
that woman who is the leader of that
organization and Ruby yeah yeah yeah she
turned out she wasn't actually buying
yeah well actually she identified as
black which is actually very true as
what she does yeah that's not what she
says she's transracial ah and I was
actually making a joke but and and if
anybody can hear if anyone can be AB you
see then then why don't we spoke we what
do we do it's right it's honestly it's
like getting rid of minorities I don't
see that as an issue I think we're all
humans anyway so so this is like all
right so this I'm done with it is the
weird thing that happens then if you're
a social liberal who thinks there really
are things we can do to benefit people
mm-hmm of like marginalized classes or
whatever you legitimately think so use a
light approach to it what's the solution
class-based issues seems to be the best
you know solution is helping with
education and with investments and
helping generational wealth and things
like that
if you want to destroy civil rights what
do you do make sure everyone has access
to every program for every marginalized
group and because what is saying when
everyone's special no one knows
yeah and that's and that's what's
happening so that's why I bring me back
to the first segment we did about black
lives matter who benefits the most or
maybe that's happening I gotta be honest
it's not the left I mean if the left's
really their goal is ultra traditional
you know militaristic government and the
removal of civil rights law it's like
keep going man that's that's not what
I'm about yeah that's what they're doing
so now um if you think about it we don't
even have a female athletics division
anymore you know when was that what was
that created the female athletic yes I
was with like title nine or something
yeah or was that yeah so you you you
have a special sporting division for
women because women don't do well
against men and then they race it and
now males are competing against females
again or I'm sorry males are just
competing and fields are being pushed
out yeah so if we go down that route why
look man when money's involved why
wouldn't you know the female division
just be trans athletes and if that's
what that's what society wants um
whatever I guess yeah eventually all the
women are gonna be pushed out because
they're not physically built like a
biological male yeah the Olympics are
supposedly going to be allowing
transgender athletes I think that's
ridiculous
uh and that's going to result to look
every country wants the gold wrecked you
know goat the gold from the Olympics
mm-hmm well then of course they're gonna
choose the best path towards victory
yeah so they're gonna seek out the best
of the best and I look at there's an
interesting argument there about
basketball okay
the argument is basketball is
disproportionately one race I think it's
a proportionately black okay yeah sure
and disor tional 'hide advantaged no one
complains about that makes sense makes
perfect sense and right so that that's
the argument they say no one complains
that there's no rules protecting short
people do you want to create a short
division for basketball
we're only people for five nice that's
ridiculous right yes it is it's a silly
sounding basketball team so the argument
from them is and there's got to be under
five foot to be on our if we don't have
the same protection
or people who just happen to be too
short to play and you end up with us
with us with sports that are dominated
by people who only are fortunately one
body type it's actually more fair
because now I think about it how many
people are over you know 6 foot 5 very
very very few people true right so
you've created you've created a sport
because there's no there's no rules that
disproportionately advantage is a tiny
micro fraction of the population what's
the difference you're right well that's
the argument they bring up yeah and it's
like do we you know they're actually
arguing though for right but is D gender
so like like equity in sports in
basketball and football could you
imagine if they were if they actually
implemented rules where it's like the
NBA teams had to be half female oh boy
it would basically just be the guy like
it should be the guys playing against
each other for the most part you just
make the team little smaller so good
fundamentals though yeah do dramas oh I
don't know I don't I don't know where
that argument takes you in the end um I
see the point but there are a lot of
sports that don't have these advantages
and you can also point out you know
Mugsy Bo's in in in the NBA was you got
five three yeah we brought about before
and he's somebody who earned it through
merit and ability but then they just say
like what's one one person out of how
many mm-hm and so yeah NBA just keeps
trying to find the best of the best and
if that's the point then why wouldn't
someone find the best of the best for
all sports all things all things yeah
how about all things so I guess the main
issue though is men and women can both
be very tall and here's the counter to
that the NBA is comprised of the best
physically fit and the best physically
applicable of the males and the best
physically fit fit and applicable of the
females we still separate based on
gender because of the the bell curve for
both genders being like you're more
likely to be like your own biological
sex than the other okay so we separate
for that reason but the are you know the
counter-argument is yes sports choose
the best of the best your point why
we're not gonna allow you know well if
I'm gonna watch a sport I want to see
the best of the best
compete yeah capitalism baby
and so the issue there is watching
someone who's biologically male compete
against females is not giving you the
best of the best for females no so you
don't get to see the best females in the
sport you can see the best you get to
see a male who didn't make it or what or
isn't competing in the male division or
whatever for whatever reason yeah yeah I
don't want to imply that they were doing
it to your eye right but you know I mean
I'm sure that happens though man I'm not
the best in the male side but I can
identify as women because I already know
that I can I'm better than that best the
best female I think I'm not saying it
happens either but I would not be
surprised well I think and I have a
feeling a lot more people think that
there are a few cases where the
individuals aren't on any therapies or
treatments okay that makes me wonder but
like that's like two of most of the
cases we've seen most of the cases we've
seen where a transgender male athlete
beats the females is there legit
transitioning yeah and there have been
only rate like there's a few instances
of people who are really exploiting it
I'm not gonna name them because I'm
deserve to be named but right oh yeah
some nasty people that's happy people
yeah
well I see a lot of female athletes that
are speaking out against it cuz they're
pissed right there like understandably
how can we compete this isn't fair
like we're we're we're the top of our
class and we're being outclassed
completely so by biological males let's
just remove all restrictions for all
sport you're playing basketball you can
have a hockey stick and rollerskates and
trampolines get thrown on the field no
rules what are the rules who wins I have
no idea but it looks crazy let's just go
for it I just total came out to fold and
we shop and watch people do weird things
and they for some reason there's a
common theme of throwing balls through
other holes like through holes of some
sort what's that what's that movie we
just watched with the is the hunter
ringer oh the ringer no no no where they
put a box of guns and stuff yeah in the
hell yeah that's how we'll do sports you
just pull just drop a bunch of players
on the field have a box and just fully
open it up and you know and there will
be hoops everywhere and there will be
goals and actually be a funny sport yeah
good at that I know that I sure who you
know they would figure out which balls
to throw mm-hmm they would have teams
they'd be like okay when we go for it
it'd be like a relay we'll call it all
ball yeah you're gonna have a guy that's
actually a cool game I like it all right
you're welcome
so because thinking about this way
you'll have special people who are in
like and that receivers that was the day
all ball was born whole ball a big crate
it just opens up and there's a button
and then it's also dodgeball it's also
you get hit by it you're done that was
good it actually be a funny game let's
keep this going man thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you